we're getting a rare look this morning
at evidence from one of the largest mass
kidnappings in US history three masked
gunmen seized a bus carrying 26 children
and their driver back in 1976 the
kidnappers drove them a hundred miles
from Chowchilla California to a rock
quarry they buried the children and the
driver alive 12 feet underground in a
moving truck while the driver and
children managed to dig themselves out
the 28 hour nightmare still haunts them
more than 40 years later our lead
national correspondent David beg note
takes an inside look at the case for 48
hours it was the summer of 1976 this bus
pulled into the small town of Chowchilla
California inside the bus were 26
traumatized children outside with a
frantic parents these children had been
through an unimaginable ordeal kidnapped
and buried alive in an old moving truck
that had been hidden beneath a rock
quarry six-year-old Larry Park was one
of those kids this man carried me off
the bus and he put me in my mom's arms
I felt I felt like I was finally safe
14-year old Michael Marshall and the bus
driver piled up mattresses that were in
the hole and after 16 hours in darkness
they managed to dig their way to safety
I'm giving it everything I got and all
the kids are cheering me on and you know
you can do it police immediately zeroed
in on 24 year old Fred woods he was the
son of the man who owned the rock quarry
and two of Fred woods his friends James
and Richard Schoenfeld Jill clingy is an
assistant district attorney in Alameda
County fred woods had keys to that
quarry investigators executed a warrant
to search fred Woods's father's estate
and they found a treasure trove of
evidence they're now shared with 48
hours
this crime was planned out for a year
and a half in intricate detail you
actually have a document
labeled plan and it sets out the way
they were going to commit the kidnapping
they also recovered a draft of a ransom
note they were going to ask for five
million dollars from the state of
California but the kidnappers were never
able to deliver their demand when they
tried to call the Chowchilla Police
Department because of the number of
calls that were coming in worldwide the
phone lines were jammed they couldn't
get through so they took a nap and by
the time they woke up they saw in the
news that the kids had been found so
they were never able to request their
ransom with the overwhelming evidence
against them the three men were arrested
all came from well-off families who
lived in some of San Francisco's nicest
suburbs they're young they're white
they're wealthy I think it added a
component of fascination to the story
because it was so unlikely that three
men such as these would commit such a
treacherous crime and David is at the
table with us this morning good morning
David what do we know about the motive
of the kidnappers exactly so this is
really interesting and this is a quote
here they said we needed multiple
victims to get multiple millions and so
we picked children because they're
precious they did put a lot of thought
into it you know back then people didn't
really talk as openly about therapy did
they offer therapy to these kids you
know Gil they took them to Disneyland
that's what they did it's because the
thought was if we go to Disneyland and
take a picture and you see Mickey Mouse
and everything's great you might forget
about what just happened and Fred Woods
was denied parole when you hear earlier
he was going to parole but he was denied
for a 17th time you know one of the
reasons why he was running a Christmas
tree farm from prison now wait a minute
that's not illegal
you just have to ask the warden for
permission he didn't another two
kidnappers they're free they're out they
followed the rules got parole all right
David thank you you can see David's 48
hours report live to tell the Chow
chilla kidnapping Saturday night at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS